tell me Liz prometheus he calls himself
Adrienne chase I need your girlfriend
exclusive what did you do now we have to
find Susan I'm ten steps ahead you can
figure out what game we're playing yes
I'm gonna finish this if you've seen the
promo for next week's episode you know
that Oliver finds out almost immediately
that Chase is prometheus what I really
like is that Chase is put himself in a
position where he doesn't have to
extricate himself from his day to day
work he can stay on as the district
attorney because he has thought so far
ahead of Oliver this year I mean if
you're planning something but the other
person doesn't know you're planning it
it doesn't make the person who's a
victim of the scheme stupid it it means
they're in the dark and Adrian has put
Oliver in checkmate which is why
conveniently the title of our next
episode is checkmate
hey everybody its charlie we got to talk
all about prometheus arrow stuff Stephen
Amell dropped a couple bombs that I
included in the video too careful for
spoilers for last week's arrow if you
haven't seen it yet
the reason I included that Stephen Amell
clip is because he did a Q&A where he
dropped a whole bunch of really cool
bombs about stuff that's coming up so I
included some of the gems from that in
this video so if a new round of the
flash ring giveaway starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment about arrow in this
video but the trailer like you says
Oliver's literally been put in checkmate
by Adrian chase so it's all about
literal checkmate but a lot of you are
big DC fans maybe you watch Smallville
they did a version of checkmate from the
comics with Amanda Waller their version
of Amanda Waller era hasn't actually
done checkmate yet they've done Argos
but the cool thing is is you know Easter
Egg from legends of tomorrow is that
Valentina Vostok the characters that
became that crazy female firestorm
during season 1 she was a member of
checkmate in the comics
enjoins to behold professor without the
splicer
without suspected deliverer being able
to control our nuclear reactions you
have to listen to me Thomas unless we
infuse you'll end up going
so the comic book well is pretty deep
but as Stephen Amell says Oliver finds
out almost immediately the Adrian chases
Prometheus and he's thought so far ahead
that he can still be the district
attorney and harass oliver during the
day just mess with his head and do
Prometheus stuff at night which is where
we get to the post-credits scene from
the last episode he grabs Susan Williams
and rigs are up in this bomb looking
trap here and then over the course of
the episode just completely torments
them you see him in this hospital here
so they mix and match a couple of things
the trailer is always broken up it's not
a linear thing so you see all of our
talking to the police chief but if you
look in this other scene over here where
they're in the hospital confronting each
other with all these machines hooked up
to this guy the guy is actually the
police chief so Prometheus is
strategically messing with Oliver's head
and also at the same time turning green
arrow into enemy number one of the city
we finally see Talia in what looks like
a modern day scene where she's
explaining Prometheus he's calling
himself Adrianne chase so it'll be
interesting to see how she ran into him
in the past there was a lot of talk
about flashback so I included Stephen
Amell Klipper is talking about how he's
really excited to not do flashbacks at
least not in the same way it's a very
different type of flashback they're
going to be doing going forward but
they'll continue to bounce back and
forth between past and present day is
they contextualize Prometheus like who
is this person now we're learning about
that in present day but who is the man
who sought out Talia to train to fight
Oliver flashbacks take up time not not
and by the way not just my time but but
story time that could be devoted to
other things and there's a general sense
of accomplishment that we set out with
the idea of telling a five-year
backstory which is a relatively
audacious thing to do for a television
show and we got a chance to complete it
all cry out late so I'm excited for
season 6 largely because I don't know
what's going to happen and on top of all
that I know a lot of you are wondering
because we have Talia does that mean
future seasons will have Talia versus
Nyssa battle to reform the League of
Assassins because as of the show right
now it doesn't exist so I think there's
a chance that they could reform it in a
future season through Talia and Nyssa
but because Katrina law the actors that
plays Nyssa is on another TV show it's
going to be
really hard to do so that might be
something that they're locking down for
season six so the other really cool
twist from last week is vigilante not
revealing their identity the producers
have said that they will not reveal that
person's identity until season six so we
already know one of the big threads
that's going to continue so like we
introduced the new black Canary
character
she'll obviously go into season six with
a big arc but now we know vigilante is
too usually they don't spin out really
big plot points for future seasons -
like the final couple episodes but now
we know that vigilante is going to
continue to be a really big character so
this is what Stephen Amell said about
vigilante it's kind of funny never
imagined Adrien being Prometheus mostly
because I thought for sure he was
vigilante my question is who is the
giant event is he also going to be
someone we least expect maybe how you
know fishy be a very tall woman but
that's okay it doesn't necessarily
confirm the vigilante is a woman it just
he's trying to say don't assume that
it's a man because the voice is really
deep and they seem kind of big it just
seems like after last week's episode
just watching them move around the way
their body looked and profile that they
could be a woman or just a really thin
looking man but the cool thing about not
revealing their identity is that when we
get to season six and they rip the mask
off they can be like oh my god it was
this person the whole time it can be a
big twist and they could pay it off in a
big way if they're not able to get the
actor on the show this season so people
always wonder why Manu Bennett can't
come on the show because he's a regular
on another show so scheduling is that
nightmare things like that I don't think
that vigilante is actually Slade Wilson
but I do think it's somebody that you
just have trouble getting on the show
this season that they're booking for
next season so it can be like oh my god
it's this huge character but along those
lines Stephen Amell dropped another big
bomb about big characters coming back or
big new characters from the comics
coming on and I think that we have to
deep this cast that we've ever had at
any point in the show actually just got
some news about that yesterday hahaha
very cool stuff
the thing about that he could be talking
about one of two things he could be
talking about a really big character
from the past like a huge deep cut
coming back or they got some really big
amazing character from one of the other
TV shows or a new character from the
comics that's going to come on so it
just confirms that really big stuff is
happening and even though arrow changes
stuff from the comics they are doing a
lot of big comic book things now and I
think as we head into like the final
seasons of the show like season 6 season
7 they'll continue to do that so let me
know in the comments who do you think
big Atlanta is do you think it's a
character from a previous season who's
come back like say Roy has put the mask
on it has gone a little bit nuts or do
you think it's a brand new character
that we haven't seen before but has some
sort of deeper meaning to the characters
what I'm going to do next is I'll post
my Walking Dead video later tonight
there's a whole bunch of Logan Easter
eggs and Deadpool stuff that I'm going
to wait to post til Monday
just because so much stuff is going on
so tomorrow Tuesday a whole bunch of
Logan Deadpool flash stuff happening all
say congratulations to last week's flash
ring giveaway winner max 11 please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video I'll announce the
winner the next time I post a CC video
while you wait for that you can click
here for next week's flash video and you
can click here for my Deadpool trailer
video thank you so much for watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys in the
next video